- [Instructor] Where we
left off in the last video,
Alexander dies in 323 BCE,
at the young age of 32.
And even though he conquered
all of this territory,
it was a very short-lived empire.
And what happens next is a period known
as the Wars of the Diadochi, and let me
write down this word, Diadochi.
Diadochi translates into successors,
and these are the various leaders,
and mainly generals, of Alexander
who then fought for control of the empire.
It's a very bloody
period, a lot of different
Diadochi going after each other,
or after each other's families,
and what eventually happens
over the next few decades
is Alexander's empire, the empire that he
establishes, gets split up
into a few major empires.
What you see on this
map here, you see most
of Persia, and the Anatolian
Peninsula right over here,
really the bulk of the old
Achaemenid Persian Empire.
It gets under control of Seleucus,
and he establishes the Seleucid dynasty,
the Seleucid Empire.
Let me write this down right here.
This is Seleucid, so the Seleucid Empire.
Egypt right over here,
this gets taken control
of another general of Alexander, Ptolemy,
and he establishes the Ptolemaic Empire
and the Ptolemaic dynasty.
Ptolemaic.
And then Macedon ends up under control
once again of another Diadochi,
remember the Diadochi are the successors,
all of these characters right over here.
These are three of the various Diadochi,
three of the more successful
Diadochi right over here.
But what the Macedonian components
of Alexander's Empire, for the most part,
end up under the control
of Antigonus's dynasty,
which ends up being called
the Antigonid dynasty.
Antigonid.
And this, and as you can see, it's not all
of the empire Alexander established.
What we have in red here,
these are independent
states that did not get subsumed
into the Seleucid, the Ptolemaic,
or the Antigonid Empires,
You can imagine, over the
next several hundred years,
they're going back and forth, there's an
ebb and flow of control
of these various empires,
but these are the three most significant,
especially the Ptolemaic and the Seleucid.
What this establishes is what a lot
of historians refer to as a new period
of especially this part of the world.
When we go from shortly
before the Persian invasions
of Greece all the way
to Alexander the Great,
we refer to that as Classical Greece,
but now we're going from Classical Greece,
with the death of
Alexander in the beginning
of the Wars of the Diadochi for control,
this sets up a new period, often referred
to by historians as Hellenistic Period.
And the Hellenistic Period is referring
to the fact that all of this territory
that was conquered by Alexander the Great,
and later gets split after
the Wars of the Diadochi
between these Diadochi
establishing these various empires,
they had huge influence of Greek culture.
You had ruling dynasties
that were essentially Greek,
whether you're in Ptolemaic Egypt,
Seleucid Persia, or Antigonid Macedonia.
Obviously the Macedonians were already
a very strong Greek culture.
And it's a time where you have the spread
of the culture, you have
a bit of fulfillment
of Alexander the Great's
goal of creating this very,
this mashup, so to speak,
of the various cultures
of the region, the Greco, and the Persian,
and the Egyptian cultures.
Now the Hellenistic Period starts to end
as each of these various
empires get overthrown.
The Seleucid Empire, in
the third century BCE,
it gets more and more overtaken
by the Parthian Empire.
Parthia starts as a satrap, a region,
of the Seleucid Empire, but it eventually
takes control over much of Persia.
So this is the Parthanian, sorry,
the Parthian Empire, right over here.
And the last vestiges
of the Seleucid Empire
are eventually defeated
by the Roman legions,
and you'll see this is a common trend here
because, at the time of Alexander,
on the Italian peninsula, you start having
a city-state that's becoming
more and more powerful,
and more and more of an empire.
And as we will see, it starts to subsume
a lot of the regions we talked about.
Ptolemaic Egypt, it gets overthrown
by the Roman Empire in 30 BCE,
and the Antigonid dynasty gets overthrown
by the Roman Empire,
they're actually the first
to get overthrown by the
Roman Empire, in 168 BC.
So this period, this Hellenistic Period,
the takeaway, it's a
period, I'm talking about
hundreds of years in a matter
of five or six minutes,
but this is a period
where you had significant
Greek influence over a very large period,
or a very large area of
land, and it eventually ends
with a lot of the western portions
falling under Roman control,
and the eastern portions,
especially Persia, falling
under Parthian control.